laufen für die meisten ein sport für
kenianer aber ist es viel mehr es ist
ruhm geldquelle und eine chance
ich laufe um zu helfen meiner familie zu
hause mir selbst meinem trainer für die
art und weise wie er mir geholfen hat
[Musik]
laufen ist in unserer gesellschaft ein
gutes geschäft oder es ist ein job es
ist ein job wie jeder andere
für die kenianische gesellschaft zu
laufen ist wirklich wichtig und
vermittelt die botschaft dass laufen das
ganze land vereinen kann
der westen kenias die stadt eldoret
drumherum unzählige lauf camps auf 2400
meter über dem meeresspiegel
hier sind alle und alles in bewegung
face charity ist es 17 jahre jung doch
ihr alltag ist getaktet wie der eines
managers um acht uhr morgens beginnt
ihre schule da hat es schon 2 stunden
intensiven sport hinter sich all das
training die mühen für ein ziel face
steht kurz vor dem durchbruch zur
weltspitze
weil laufen sehr wichtig ist und es mir
in zukunft helfen wird
ich werde ein guter mensch sein ich
werde meiner familie helfen und ich
werde denen helfen die mir und anderen
menschen helfen
um 16 uhr ist face auf dem heimweg ihre
eltern und die sieben geschwister sind
vier busstunden entfernt sie sieht sie
nur alle paar wochen
gemeinsam mit fünf mädchen wohnen face
bei der familie ihres trainers jede
minute gehört dem einen traum
ich sage meinen freundinnen immer dass
sie stark sein müssen und weiter hart
arbeiten müssen damit sie sich
verbessern
so wie ich mich auch verbessere damit
ich in der zukunft meinen job habe
face trainer donnert rondo weiß wie hart
es ist erfolgreich zu sein eine
verletzung beendete seine eigene
karriere um sich als coach über wasser
zu halten fährt der bruder bruder ein
motorrad taxi all seine hoffnung auf
eine eigene bessere zukunft hut jetzt
aus einem 17 jährigen mädchen
balsamo alle mädchen sind
disziplinierter und fleißiger
sie hören auf den trainer und
respektieren sich selbst
wenn man sich selbst respektiert
respektiert man auch alle anderen
vielleicht ohne respekt kann man es
nirgendwo hin schaffen
respekt und disziplin wohl kaum einer
steht in kenia dafür sowie eliot kippte
das idol aller marathonläufer hat es aus
bescheidensten verhältnissen geschafft
wenn kipchoge rennen läuft sich die
nation vor dem fernseher darauf ist er
stolz
ich bin ein vorbild dafür ein kenianer
zu sein nicht ein stammes kenianer
laufen kann unser land zusammen bringen
deshalb sage ich immer wir laufen als
einheit
was liegt so gemeint noch immer sind
peanuts politik und alltag von
ethnischen konflikten geprägt wer zu
welchem volk gehört sieht eine große
rolle auch für die
präsidentschaftswahlen nächstes jahr
gibt vogel selbst ein andy will das auch
mit seiner person seinem sport
überwinden
es ist gut zu einem stamm zu gehören
aber es ist schlecht ein stamm zu sein
das ist es was ich immer sage ist und
was ich immer verkaufen wir gehören alle
zu vielen stimmen aber wir sind alles
menschen also seid bitte nicht stammes
bezogen aber der laufsport wird das
stammesdenken in unserem land überwinden
das seminar kann auch ist ajax kate
räumte einst von einer karriere wie
kippe noch heute kann er die marathons
der welt weit lief aufzählen er lebte
vom laufen seine bestzeit 2 stunden 13
minuten eine spitzenzeit doch dann kamen
die verletzungen kosgei der bis dahin
nur die grundschule besuchte musste als
erwachsener wieder von vorne anfangen
ich habe vier jahre eine schuluniform
getragen krawatte schuhe pulli socken
und all das es war nicht leicht in der
klasse mit kleinen kindern zusammen zu
sitzen aber ich habe es geschafft alle
sagten ja mach s go for it und es war
eine gute entscheidung
denn bildung ist macht
[Musik]
mit hilfe der läufer community bekam der
heute 47-jährige ein stipendium für eine
ausbildung zum physiotherapeuten in
europa der dreifache vater ist stolz auf
seine kleine praxis mit der er seine
familie finanziert
auch komme aus bescheidenen
verhältnissen
wir sind neun geschwister in unserer
familie ich bin die nummer 7 ich habe
wir sehen wie lauf haben mein leben
verändert denn ohne das laufen hätte ich
nicht die ganze welt bereisen ich war in
mehreren ländern in mehr als 24 ländern
durch das laufen kenne ich also die welt
und es ist auch ein abenteuer für mich
das macht mich glücklich
es sind menschen wie kostbar die der
region selbstbewusstsein verleihen die
kleine orte zu trainingsstätten von
weltstars machen und damit zum wohlstand
der gemeinden beitragen
auch facility träumt davon bei der wm im
hindernislauf der unter 20-jährigen hat
sie vor ein paar monaten bronze gewonnen
500.000 kenia schilling etwa 4000 euro
hat sie damit verdient eine große summe
für ihre familie und eine große last für
die junge 17 jährige
ich sage meiner familie dass es mir gut
geht und dass ich stark bleibe und dass
sie weiter für mich beten und mich
motivieren sollen damit ich gut
weitermachen kann
[Musik]
um acht uhr abends ist face tag vorbei
morgens um fünf geht es wieder los
laufen für sie nicht nur ein sport
sondern eine chance und die hoffnung auf
ein besseres leben für sie und ihre
familie
[Musik]